[Music]
one useful way to organize our
understanding of reality is to think in
terms of things that are either very big
like stars in black holes
very small like molecules atoms and
subatomic particles or very complex
aggregates of many particles that are
highly ordered or structured
tonight we're going to focus on one of
these three categories the complex
the human brain
now it is not uncommon to hear the brain
described as the most complex structure
in the entire universe but
as we have such a meager knowledge of
what might be out there i for one am not
ready to make that commitment and
there's no need to the brain is complex
and its functions not just wondrous but
the very substrate of who we are as
individuals and as a species so the pull
to understand the brain is strong
this program is called decoding the
brain because the work of all the
scientists we'll be speaking with in one
way or another is contributing to a
deeper understanding of the cascading
electrical processes crackling through
our brains which somehow result in our
experiences our emotions and our
behaviors
in short we will explore
various ways that new tools that allow
us to directly probe brain processes are
helping to reveal
that most complex of objects here on
earth
the human brain
[Music]
our first guest is michael holasa who is
the class of 1958 career development
professor at mit's department of brain
and cognitive sciences
and is also an associate investigator at
mit's mcgovern institute for brain
research his aim is to understand the
basic architecture and the functional
connections in the brain that underlie
cognition
and he has identified basic circuit
mechanisms for attention and decision
making he joins us from his home
outside of boston welcome michael thank
you brian great to be here our next
guest is edward chang who is the joan
and samford wild chairman of the
department of neurological surgery at
the university of california san
francisco he co-directs the center for
neural engineering and prosthesis which
brings together engineers and
neuroscientists to develop technology
that can restore function to patients
with neurological disabilities he joins
us from san francisco welcome eddie hi
brian
our next guest is michael cahanna who is
the edmond j and louise w khan term
professor of psychology at the
university of pennsylvania where he is
the principal investigator at the
university's computational memory lab
he studies human episodic memory and is
currently working on building a
prosthetic device to enhance it he joins
us from his office in
philadelphia thank you brian welcome
michael happy to be here our next guest
is helen mayberg who is the director of
the center of advanced circuit
therapeutics and a professor of
neuroscience neurology neurosurgery and
psychiatry at the icann school of
medicine at mount sinai she has done
pioneering work to uncover the neural
circuitry of depression and to treat it
via deep brain stimulation she joins us
from her office in new york welcome
helen nice to be here brian finally we
have yuri birjaki who is the biggs
professor of neuroscience at new york
university of medicine he is the author
of the brain from inside out in which he
proposes new paradigm for the study of
the brain and he is currently decoding
the underlying patterns by which the
brain operates he joins us from his
office
in new york welcome yuri thank you brian
so thank you all for joining us and let
me start with a
basic question that's really to the
group i'd love to hear all of you chime
in if you have a perspective on it which
is this
do
any of you have a preferred metaphor for
thinking about the working of the mind
and what do you think about the computer
metaphor is it a is it a reasonable way
of thinking about the brain for some
purposes or is it a metaphor
that should be retired so maybe we'll
begin with uh eddie chang
you know from where i stand
it's it's actually very hard for me to
think about the brain like a computer
because when i go to the operating room
and see it every week it doesn't look
anything like a computer its substrate
is
fundamentally different but we use the
analogy all the time and so
in our work it is helpful to frame some
questions in terms of the information
processing
of the mind in in the framework of a
computer
but there's so much more that goes on
that it's generated from the internal
model that's inside the mind in the
substrate of the brain
that is far beyond what modern computers
do right now
in fact i think the analogy for
computers in the future might be more
like
the mind as opposed to the other way
around michael halasa yeah that's a
great question brian and i sort of echo
what eddie already mentioned
i should say that um
you know one of the
things that i think about quite a lot is
is the idea of scales in the brain
and
this
multi-scale organization and the
vertical integration across these scales
and i think some of these scales
computer science can be extremely
valuable in providing the language to
describe them i think what we're
potentially lacking is
a
vertically integrated theory to connect
all of these scales in a way that would
be
helpful to to connect them um to real
world applications so while the metaphor
may work for certain scales at certain
times i think we're we're just missing a
a unifying theory for for neuroscience
to make sense of all of these ideas sure
helen thoughts on that well i think it's
interesting because as a neurologist
studying
a psychiatric disorder like depression
one wanted to start with modules and to
think about modular organization but i
think like michael says you know
thinking at different scales is really
critical and i think maybe the one
metaphor of depression to this
conversation is the nature of it feels
like a black hole as kind of an
attractor state and as soon as you
enter that metaphor into the
conversation the idea of a computer kind
of
quantifying that or giving us an
organizational structure becomes a
little tougher so um i'm really
interested in how yuri answers this
question
well that's a good lead in yuri
metaports are useful and we don't have
anything else the way how the brain
works is it always compares
we know the unknown with the help of the
known so we always ground something that
we don't understand with the help of
something we think we do such as a
computer
and this is a this is a a useful
metaphor
but we have a lot of other things that
are
blocking this and the reason why we are
taking this this way is because
uh
is the computer world that took the
initiative and says oh
you know this is like the brain and the
reason why the computers and computer
scientists think like about the brain is
because they took the wrong brain model
and the wrong brain model is that the
brain is a passive device just like a
computer into which you shovel
information
and the computer has no choice
the human mind doesn't have the choice
this is what called the tabula rasa or
the blank slate model and this is not by
chance you know that that one of the
giants of the the of ai and computer
scientist alan turing explicitly said
that the brain the newborn brain is like
a white paper onto which we have to this
prescribe things and this is where we
we fill it up now just by saying that
the the real problem here is that
the if you follow this recipe from the
brain and ai then the the complexity of
the
human brain of any brain or the ai
system depends on the amount of
information you put in and i can tell
you later why i think it doesn't so
that's a fundamental difference the
brain is a self-organized system
whereas the computer is a man-made
machine
right yeah so we will have a time to
discuss that in more detail a bit later
on but michael kahana thoughts on the
metaphors of choice for thinking about
thinking yeah so those are all great
points and uh i love
yuri's point about a self-organizing
system the metaphor that got me
interested in memory was from condensed
matter theory spin glass systems or
complex thermodynamic systems where a
system could be in multiple states i
mean a simple example would be water it
could be solid liquid or gas but even
more complex systems exist in nature and
so that metaphor i found very appealing
as a way of thinking about the brain
differently
from the computer analogy and in line
with the idea of a self-organizing
system that you already mentioned with
that as a preamble let's jump in to some
of the
astounding really remarkable work that
you all have been pioneering eddie i'm
going to start with you your focus at
least for some time has been on
understanding
the neural circuitry of speech with i
gather one of the goals being to
to be able to have some sensors that can
have some understanding of the
electrical and other properties that are
happening in the brain and from those
signals be able to get some
understanding of what the patient is
trying to say so can you give us a sense
of what your approach has been and what
you have found
sure so
our approach has been to understand the
neural code
for our ability to articulate words and
speak
and what i mean by that is the
patterning of electrical activity
that's generated by
the brain activity in the temporal lobe
and in the mortar cortex that's above it
it's a very precise coordination of
neural activity that gives rise to
words and sentences
and so for the past decade we've worked
with
patients of ours in in san francisco at
the university of california san
francisco who have volunteered as
part of medical
treatments that they've had for
treatment of their seizures when
implanted electrodes were placed
directly on the brain surface with very
very small sensors maybe the ones you're
referring to
to record that electrical activity at
the order of millimeters and
milliseconds
and with those kind of recordings we've
been able to decipher and correlate
those electrical brain patterns with
individual consonants and vowels
as well as syllables
in order to give rise to words so if i
was one of those patients you would ask
me to
imagine
saying words and you'd monitor what goes
on inside my head when i'm doing that
yeah a lot of what we focused on
actually was not so much about imagining
speaking but actually the actual
production of words so what i mean by
that is um when i'm speaking these words
right now
how does the neural activity at one
particular spot about a millimeter wide
control the movements of my tongue in a
very particular trajectory to create a
duh
sound or the sight that's right next to
it
that controls my lips when we make the
sun
so there is a map
that controls basically all of the very
precise movements of the vocal tract and
we study that when people are speaking
normally but also in other conditions
for example when they are imagining
or um sometimes even speaking different
languages and is it important that
you're getting the patient to actually
say the words the physical act of speech
as opposed to the mental act of
imagining a word do those give radically
different signals if you try to measure
them yeah great question we've looked at
that pretty carefully and it turns out
that imagining speaking
is very very different than
actually speaking
so the act of speaking uh is a fully
intentional and volitional
event whereas when you're just thinking
about
a thought or
or even imagining the words it's a
different neural activity pattern that's
much more subtle and complex and that we
have a lot more work to figure out how
that works but the actual production of
of of words has become much more clear
over the last five years and is it
fairly consistent across distinct
patients if everybody intends to
articulate cat or
the same signal by and large is
generated yeah that's right so everyone
has
a little bit of variability in the
absolute position of where these
locations are in the brain but they are
confined to
the sensory motor cortex of
of the part of the brain that controls
the parts of our vocal tract and when
you look at the precise position of all
of those neurons it can be highly
variable from one individual to another
but when you look at the patterns at a
higher order they're actually really
remarkably similar
and so do you have kind of a like a
dictionary or a map
yeah both uh basically it's a map of the
different articulators of the vocal
tract and
the the target sounds that we try to
speak
when we articulate words
and we call it a dictionary because
for example in english there's only
about 40 phonemes different speech
sounds that give rise to every possible
syllable in word
so a dictionary is a very useful way of
thinking about it is that you've got
this elemental
set of units that by themselves have no
meaning but in combination can give rise
to every possible meaning so you
basically just go through that that
exhaustive or fairly exhaustive list of
elementary building blocks map those out
and then you can stick them together i
gather in your dictionary to get to
generate more or less anything that
somebody would say yeah exactly and when
when you when i you know when when you
say exhaustive something that's very
important to think about that is just in
the couple of minutes that we've already
spoken
we've gone through most of that
dictionary
not just once but a couple of times so
just by simple conversation just by
simple speaking through um you know
random sentences even you can sample all
of this and what's really incredible
about it is that as people generate new
sentences we're resampling from that
that core dictionary that core set of
units and recombining of ways to give
rise to completely new meanings and
sentences
and then i presume then you can test
this on on new subjects and determine
how well
your system does at decoding
the signatures in the brain that are
being read through the implants
yeah that's right so
we can essentially take that code and um
in the same person or in a different
person with some modifications of that
code
essentially translate
that brain activity for a completely new
sentence
and reconstruct just from the brain
activity alone
what someone wanted to say or actually
said and how well do you do
i think we're starting to get to the
point where
things are starting to sound
intelligible so for example
if you wanted to translate brain
activity into words and sentences that
you actually hear with your ears using
speech synthesis using a machine
algorithm to translate the brain
activity to actual sounds that you hear
through speech synthesis
we're starting to get to the point where
it's intelligible
which for us isn't a really important
milestone there's a lot of room for
improvement but where we are right now
is that you can actually make out the
words even though they're kind of fuzzy
the print that you are seeing is signal
rolling wheels
the proof that you are seeking is not
available in books
she feel the video must mess any process
ship building is a most fascinating
process
so we're really excited in terms of
achieving that milestone yet there's
still a lot more to do to make it better
that's fascinating work eddie michael
gahanna let's let's turn to you
there's not a person among us who
wouldn't love the prospect that we hear
in sci-fi scenarios of one day being
able to enhance
our memories through some kind of
medical intervention and i know that you
have begun work in that direction so
just to get us going
how well
do we understand the process the
biological process by which memories are
formed in the brain well i would say
that we still are at a very very early
primitive stage in our understanding of
the biological processes of the
formation of memories but we do have a
very good ability to decode
neural signals that predict whether or
not memories will be stored and whether
or not they will be
accurately retrieved
so you're treating the memory
imprinting process as a kind of a black
box i guess and saying we don't really
understand how it's happening in the
brain but we're just going to observe it
and find the patterns do you feel that
ultimately you're going to need to
understand the process itself that's
happening inside of our brains or can we
just treat it like that black box
well i think that you need to proceed on
multiple uh tracks if you want to
address uh the one in 12 americans for
example who have
significant memory loss then you want to
move forward before you wait to have a
full understanding or even a good
approximate understanding of the
underlying processes governing the
storage and retrieval of memories but i
think that the most interesting process
in the brain is the process by which we
retrieve memories rather than the
process by which we store memories
because
memory retrieval
you might have a memory that's stored
really well i mean you've experienced
this thing many times and uh you clearly
this this memory pops into mind often
and then you find yourself in a
situation where you need that
information you just can't find it right
so something is going on the memory is
there and and if you just think about
the fact that we walk around with
vast stores of knowledge of experience
of memories in our mind and yet at any
given moment our ability to access that
information is really quite limited it
makes you really wonder about the
process of memory search how do we
search our memories how do we retrieve
them and we can't just look at every
single we can't go through the library
and look at every index card we need a
mechanism by which to to find those
memories so tell us about the work that
you've done in that regard in trying to
understand that in more detail and also
i gather
in trying to develop approaches that
might enhance
the ability of an individual to retrieve
those memories
well so i think most of us wonder why is
one person's memory good and another
person's memory is bad why can't i
remember things the way i used to when i
was much younger but there is a
fascinating paradox or mystery about
memory which is that within a given
person
at a given time let's say today
my memory is going to fluctuate between
periods of better and worse function
there will be a dynamic process by which
my memory varies in my ability to
access those memories that i know in my
ability to create new memories and we
can prove
with detailed experimental studies that
that variability is not due to some un
unexplained external experimental
factors but it's something in the brain
it's something in my head that makes
memory good at times and not good at
other times so now if you can decode
that physiologically if you can use
electrodes to measure electrical signals
the brain is after all an electrical
network if you can measure those
electrical signals and forecast when
you're going to have a memory lapse
using the electrical signals recorded
from the brain
then the idea would be that maybe you
could make the brain look more like its
best when it is at its worst and so the
idea is that if you first can decode or
forecast this complex system that's
varying
and then you can pinpoint the moments of
a memory lapse and somehow coax or nudge
the system from this
worse state to this better state the
better state is a state that we know the
brain can express then perhaps you could
meaningfully improve memory and that's
the kind of therapeutic approach that my
my team is taking and so are you
working with human subjects and
subjecting them to various memory tests
and seeing when they're doing well and
when they're not and recording what's
happening inside their head and building
up the correlation in that way is that
is that the approach that's exactly
right we have a patient who is
undergoing the same kind of
neurosurgical evaluation
as
what dr eddie chang described
will play in instead of playing games
where they speak or listen to speech
they're going to play memory games in my
in my work
and we'll track moments of good memory
and moments of poor memory and then
we'll try to see whether we can build a
mathematical model so that tomorrow when
we come back to the patient's bedside
and they play the game we can predict
when their memory is going to be good
and when it's not moment to moment and
now if that mathematical model is
providing a reasonably accurate forecast
prediction
we can now use
very gentle electrical stimulation of
the brain to try to coax the brain into
a better memory state and so what we do
is we track those fluctuations in memory
in real time so we determine at any
moment whether you're about to forget
something whether you're going to have
trouble remembering something and then
we apply electrical stimulation at the
moment when memory is predicted to fail
aligned with the kind of stimulation
that would generally push it in the
direction of a better forecast of good
memory
and in that way you can significantly
improve memory in many patients how
significant well you know it's variable
from person to person the if if you
asked uh how significant in terms of
percent memory improvement it's about 19
improvement in different studies between
15 and 20 percent in our latest work
19.2 percent
um if you ask what does it mean for your
memory to be 19.2
better like what does that number mean
19.2 percent
that is about half
a little bit more than half
of the deficit that would be incurred in
a patient who had a moderate to severe
traumatic brain injury so in other words
that would be on average restoring half
of the loss in memory in such a patient
and really what that means is that for
let's say a third of the patients it
would be almost fully restoring that
loss for a third it doesn't do anything
and for a third it's about a a half
restoration of that loss of memory
fascinating let me move from that to uh
michael halassa who
michael you've been focusing on
focusing right you've been focusing on
trying to understand
what it is to have attention
and and whether for instance another
metaphor that we've certainly all used
which is kind of this this spotlight of
attention you know that's that's the
thing that the brain is illuminating you
know that's the thing that we're focused
on
what have you learned is that is that a
good metaphor for thinking about the
things that hold our attention or is
there another
view of awareness and attention that's
emerged from your research so brian i'm
gonna take a roundabout way to answer
your question having followed
you know eddie and and michael kahana in
in what they talked about so uh uh
they they they talked about
action you know on
from from eddie's perspective you know
articulation moving
um
and and and memory and and and i think
there is a case to be made that
one of the primary purposes of having a
brain is to plan our next action right
without without without the ability to
move and act on the world it makes no
sense to have a brain in the first place
that's why plants don't have a brain
and um
you know as you go up in evolution
organisms that are better able to plan
the sequences of their actions have
bigger brains
have bigger internal models of how they
control those uh
those actions over prolonged periods of
time
and there's a temporal hierarchy there
and and ultimately they have a pretty
good way of using these stored patterns
of past inputs that we call memory
right and my work has been on this
um
sort of intermediate
uh level of organization
between temporally speaking between
action immediate action and long-term
memory
which is this idea of cognitive control
one of one of one of the aspects by
which we control
um
our cognition is through attention how
do how we how we prioritize incoming
sensory information how we filter them
and then how we sort of
format them in a way that would be
appropriate for both short-term and
long-term action planning so we talk
about making models of the world which
is vital right because look we're
inundated by information all the time i
mean right now i'm just sitting here in
this theater and the electromagnetic
waves that are impinging on my eye
you've got these oscillating electric
fields and magnetic fields trillions of
times a second if i was sensitive to
even that information at that level of
description my brain would be
overwhelmed right to trying to cope with
that data so what does the brain do
to to cope with this influx of
information so i think that's a
fascinating question and i think it's
helpful to you know coming from mit i
think it's helpful to invoke david marr
mar stipulated that we can think of the
brain as we can think of a computer as
uh and i'm not saying the brain is a
computer i'm just saying this is a
helpful metaphor for approximating the
types of things that we do as
neuroscientists to understand the brain
there's a computational level that the
high level objective that we're trying
to accomplish for any particular neural
process the algorithmic level which is
what are the
series of steps that the brain could
take in order to to to sort of perform
this computation and then the
implementational level how is this
actually
implemented in neural hardware in
spiking neurons
right and for any particular neural
operation
i think thinking about things in this
particular way and this in that sort of
division is helpful
and
an understanding ultimately may be how
we link these different levels of
description to one another where it
becomes natural to talk about you know
the algorithms of the mind implemented
in neural hardware of spiking neurons
the work that we've you know done in my
lab has focused on the implementation to
the algorithmic level so we we record
from individual spiking neurons in the
brain in areas like the prefrontal
cortex this this front part of the brain
and that's where we think a lot of
cognitive control operations are
generated
and
the way by which we imagine they control
things like
what memory should we retrieve or what
things should we pay attention to is by
sending what we call these top-down
instructions to downstream
uh neural circuits to change their
operation in such a way that we dampen
the noise on the things that we don't
care about we amplify the signals on the
things that we care about and you know
we retrieve the memories that we
currently are are looking for we upload
the memories that we care about and so
on is is it accurate to say that the
brain then from a hardware perspective
and perhaps an algorithmic perspective
too
has kind of
gatekeepers
that information is trying to make it up
to the place of attention and awareness
but those gatekeepers are only letting
some things through is that a reasonable
way of thinking about it that's a great
analogy and i would say that it's not
just in the domain of sensory systems
i would say that this is in the domain
of cognition as well
i think that even and i i'm gonna make
uh you know sort of a conjecture here
that um even when we are trying to
retrieve you know generative hypotheses
about what's going on in the world
we we
i would say most people
would be going through this filtering
process
in order to sort of maximize the
likelihood of what's out there right i
mean these are statistical inference
machinery that we have in our brain to
infer what's going on in the outside
world and we have these things
automatically running in the background
all the time to arrive at the world as
we see it out there i think in certain
disorders for example like psychosis
schizophrenia etc these these kinds of
inferential filtering mechanisms at the
level of cognition
uh are impaired and and that's why we
end up seeing i think i mean again this
is my sort of leading hypothesis of
what's going on in some of these
illnesses is that these filtering
operations in that domain
are impaired and you end up with folks
you know
gen
and concluding
that the fbi is after them aliens are
landing in their backyard etc
fascinating
so so helen we've seen a lot of
discussion
to this point
regarding patterns in the brain that
give us insight into words and speech in
eddie chang's work insight into
memory retrieval michael kahana's work
issues of attention and awareness
gatekeeper aspects of the brain and
michael halas work your work is also as
i understand it focused upon
patterns in the brain but your
focus has been on
the patterns that correspond to
depression
so can you give us a sense of of
what that work has revealed
is there is there a kind of uniform
mental brain
pattern that one can associate with that
kind of an affective disorder so i think
it's important first to kind of define
the term i mean depression is really a
very common and serious medical illness
and i'll make the argument that it's a
brain illness we can put people in
scanners and we can get maps of what is
the topography the functional topography
of brain areas that are abnormal and it
turns out there's not just one spot none
of these
complex systems but even in these
syndromes if you have problems with
mood
and drive and thoughts and actions it's
no big surprise that you see
multiple brain areas acting together or
actually not acting together that are
abnormal and those can be mapped
and one can subsequently map
how the dynamics of the brain changes
with treatments and our work on decoding
so to speak or actually our use of
causal manipulations in the brain not
just with medication or therapy but in
real time
with electrodes helps us to see that you
can go from no capacity at all
to within seconds minutes have a total
shift
of actually how you can see
the outside world when you are stuck
internalized can you tell us a little
bit more about exactly that so if you
have um
a patient who is depressed clinically
diagnosed as depressed presumably the
patterns of the brain are sufficiently
recognizable that simply by looking at
that data you would recognize that that
would be the appropriate diagnosis can
you go that far
in
lining them up well i think that you
know we like to think so that we work in
groups of patients you know our team has
taken the approach of diagnose
depression by standard of practice
throw people in a scanner take a resting
state
picture of the brain
treat people with different kinds of
treatments for
you know three months
you're either well or you're not go back
to the beginning and see if you can tell
the difference of how people responded
it's working now that you can start to
look at an individual patient to make a
decision about which way to treat and we
and others are trying to look at that
kind of treatment specific biomarker but
it's the same network in the brain but
in different states so the question is
is every patient different
is or is there one pattern there's not
one pattern because we don't know
what the instigator is of depression and
by the time a patient is ill
there are many maladaptive patterns that
you're seeing and so you're really
trying to wade through all of this noise
to get at the kernel that might be
helpful and at that point is you know as
yuri said the self-organizing system is
totally self-organized to try to adapt
and now you actually have to figure out
what are the state you're in you're now
lost
so how do you take someone lost and
figure out what you can do to move them
back into a place where they can retrain
and be found and and that's really
it's become much more clear in our work
with implants
what that really means that was harder
to see when people were less sick so
with the implants and you mentioned this
this really stunning result of in
minutes you mentioned sometimes you can
see a change in a person you just tell
us a little bit about that how are you
stimulating that person was it through
some kind of electrode in the brain and
and what was the response like in some
of these remarkable cases
so a there have been many now so i
started this um 15 years ago in toronto
with a team and neurosurgery team andres
lozano sid kennedy a psychiatrist we
basically took the hypothesis based on
this imaging
on this map that we had that really told
us there were brain areas that were
working together but their synchrony
was um
dysregulated and we basically had reason
to believe that one area deep in the
brain seemed to be the ringleader it was
really focus the subclosal cingulate
connections to midline thalamus like
michael talks about its connections to
the hippocampus that my kahana talks
about its connections to the frontal
cortex to the hypothalamus to other
parts of the brain stem it seemed to be
focused in a place that if it didn't
change it wreaked havoc on everything
else we didn't take epilepsy patients we
took depressed people who had failed
multiple drugs psychotherapy
electroconvulsive shock therapy they're
pretty much at the end of the line
they were in that attractor state they
are stuck and they can't get out and we
basically said can we
leverage the technology that's used in
parkinson's implant with anatomical
precision
in this area and in the white matter
that connects it to these other areas in
this putative circuit
and actually when we stimulate at high
frequency it's like we release
the lockdown of this region and people
kind of come out of it so as we got
better and better at it with our imaging
we can plan the surgery
precisely within millimeters place it at
this convergence of these multiple
pathways that we know
interact with each other and we know
that from animal studies we know that
from epilepsy studies and when we apply
the high frequency stimulation we can
predict that someone will emerge and
what they describe is that the negative
turns off
and it's as though they kind of come
back online they can pay attention they
feel connected they feel like they can
move so the paralysis
kind of
goes away and and that happens very
rapidly and if you give the stimulation
even in the operating room
10 15 minutes so that we can record and
actually see what happens
we leave the operating room and they'll
stay well you know several weeks without
further stim
and then we actually turn it on and give
stimulation and we have patients that
have these chronic implants
have this pacemaker on all the time
and people are better and go about their
business so that we've reset something
very fast and then we've allowed the
brain again i'll use this
self-organizing principle to re-learn
who you are with a brain that doesn't
get stuck yeah that's remarkable helen
that a a little electrical nudge at the
right spot in the brain can have such a
dramatic long-term effect now michael
kahana you've also found that the right
electrical nudge can have a big impact
elevating the capacity of patients to
retrieve memories so michael when you
add these tiny little electrical
impulses to the brain i'm i'm assuming
the patient doesn't feel it they only
feel the
repercussions of that stimulation so
this is truly you are manipulating the
brain the patient doesn't know when
you're doing it but yet they will show a
difference on these memory exams that
shows a marked difference from before
and after
what we do is we apply stimulation these
stimulation protocols randomly on
certain lists of certain memory games
the game might be like 30 seconds or a
minute trial with or without the patient
doesn't know the experimenter doesn't
know and that's how we gauge the
beneficial effects
and so do you think that
the ability to read these signals and
even to manipulate these signals which
is what you're doing now
will this ultimately lead to a full
understanding of the process of memory
retrieval and i would love to memory
formation as well is this the root
toward that goal yeah i mean i think
that that's a really critical question
that we want to know the answer to
meaning if you have people
let's assume that we can create a
therapy that's whose benefit is
sufficiently meaningful that many people
who need the therapy will get the
therapy and the risk is low and the
benefit is high and now you have people
walking around with devices that decode
variable memory states in the brain and
transmit those signals encrypted to a
cloud which is able to analyze those
signals and build up a
massive database of information about
how the brain operates when you're
studying and recalling information or
even just acting doing your regular
activities of daily life once you have
that massive database you could imagine
that you could begin to test theories
out and improve and refine theories much
like you know maybe the hubble telescope
or some other devices give you insights
into the cosmos this kind of technology
could give us tremendous insights into
an understanding of memory encoding and
memory retrieval eddie the technology
you've developed synthesizes speech
based on the intention to form
words have you applied this in
situations when the individual is speech
impaired for
for some reason has it been able to work
in those circumstances right well that's
a great question so for the past five
years five ten years we've really
focused on what that
basic
science that basic neuroscience of this
code
for all of the different consonants and
vowels and movements of the uh the vocal
tract to give rise to speech
and about two years ago um because of
the results of that that foundational
work we started a clinical trial
actually called the bravo trial
in which we enrolled the first
participant it was a it was a young
gentleman who
at the time when he enrolled in study
was 35 years old and
the reason he was a participant in this
study was that 15 years ago
he was in a car accident that
led to complications of a brain stem
stroke
with the inability to
move his arms and legs
as well as to speak
and so uh for us that was a very
important development in the last two
years to move a lot of what we had
studied
um in the context of people who are
normally speaking
to a clinical context in the situation
of someone who is fully paralyzed who
has the full capacity
and intent to speak in the cerebrum in
the cerebral cortex but couldn't because
of a disconnection in the brain stem
[Music]
and we were able to translate that brain
activity
in into four words
the proof of principle is there and that
it is possible to really leverage that
rich rich information of those patterns
of neural activity to give rise to
things that are so human and so intimate
like words and speech yeah it's
fascinating work
michael halasa unlike eddie and helen
and mike kahana i understand that you
work primarily with animals rather than
with humans so how do you go about that
so we we train them on decision making
tasks in which they uh need to retrieve
a reward it's it's what we call uh
alternative choice tasks so we on every
and we do it trial by trial so on every
trial we give the animal the option of
choosing between
two options
and the animal is required to
do this based on appropriately deploying
attention so on every trial for example
it gets
a visual or an auditory target
and it has to pick the appropriate one
we train it
to be sensitive to a cue beforehand
so we cue it on every trial and we can
make that cue
sort of
ambiguous so basically we can we can
make this process of attention
a decision-making process decide what to
pay attention to based on ambiguous
input and that allows us to study how
the brain decides to what to pay
attention to and both the filtering at
the level of the cognitive operation
and the filtering at the level of the
sensory operation
and those animals typically is that mice
or dogs or cats yeah so so
a lot of the work that
we have published so far are in mice
and the reason why we choose mice is
because they are
they're mechanistically tractable we can
go in and turn circuits on and off
uh using
a technology called optogenetics and we
can talk about that later and then in
more recent studies uh we've been using
uh this organism called the tree shroom
tepaya and and that's a that's an
organism that's sort of intermediate
between uh rodents and primates and that
allows us the same kind of mechanistic
accessibility but we can achieve high
level cognition and study things like
causal inference in these in these
animals if schizophrenia for instance
aligns with the theoretical description
that you're imagining somehow the
gatekeeper not doing its work does that
suggest a particular
treatment or or course of action or is
it too early for that kind of a
diagnostic i can tell you where my
intuition comes from
so my intuition comes from studying a
particular circuit from the frontal
cortex the prefrontal cortex
which is particularly developed in
humans and
and its connection to a structure called
the meteorothalamus the part of the
thalamus uh
or essential structure in the brain
in schizophrenia patients
those connections you know the
structural integrity of these
connections are impaired and that's been
known for a long time
in in my lab and others in the community
we've been studying this particular
network in in um
in animals and what we've been finding
is that a lot of these uh cognitive
filtering operations sort of
deciding which evidence you should use
in order to deploy your attention
goes through those circuits
almost the algorithm is is is going
through different refresh cycles between
these two structures
and in that you know in that um uh
process the thalamus really acts as a
filter for how reliable the information
that you're getting is
so the sort of the idea that patients
and animals when we when we um uh impair
those struggles when we inhibit those
those connections end up jumping to
unlikely conclusions
basically leads us to conclude
that you know this is a reasonable
hypothesis to have about these impaired
inferential mechanisms in schizophrenia
zuri so we've
heard from a lot of
researchers the four researchers
on the discussion here tonight
eddie talking about
looking at the brain finding the
patterns that decodes to language the
michaels on memory and attention hell
and on other patterns that allow us to
understand
aspects of depression and even have
suggested ways to
address that situation that have been
remarkably effective
all of that
i believe you would describe as the
outside-in
approach to understanding the brain you
know we as third-party observers we
objective scientists are studying some
aspect of patterns inside the brain and
with that third-party perspective
trying to do something to the brain in
order to get the pattern to change or to
read the pattern or to do something with
a pattern
i gather your view is that yes this is
profound work but i think that you
suggest that there's another way of
thinking about it that ultimately you
think is the way forward give us a sense
of of what that is and you know
historically research in the brain or on
the brain has been
working its way
in from the outside world hoping that
such systematic approach will take us to
the middle
and all through the middle to the output
which is the action
now of course people didn't start out as
a neuroscientist early thinkers were
thinking about the importance of psyche
the soul the mind and so on and
they were speculating
and that speculation was codified by
christian philosophers and then the
british empiricist the bottom line of
all of this is that the brains the human
brains are there to
learn the truth of the world that is
outside
in its entity and its beauty and in the
process we realize that we need to
explain various things and so we made up
terms such as attention
memory
decision making
creativity
imagination scratch pad memory working
area that can go on and on and on and on
there are many many many words
so when neuroscience entered the scene
it seemed that we already have a task we
are on the right
road we have a road map what we have to
do namely to find
homes to all of these terms
and see how they work
i think you agree with me that this is a
naive approach
because those boundaries that we made up
in our minds and those boundaries that
smart people a thousand years ago
hundreds of years ago they made up as a
term
cannot really have a
mechanism with the same boundaries
inside the brain
now
just to give you an example this is uh
this outside inner brow which is also
you used to be called the tabula rasa or
the black slate model and so on with the
understanding that you just have to
shovel knowledge into the brain because
the brain is a receiver that is there
ready to
absorb all the information that comes
from outside
so for example
when we inspect an elephant which has a
shape size smell and so on then the goal
is to figure out how
the brain combines or binds those
attributes into a representation or into
a symbol
and it becomes a symbol of the elephant
there is a fundamental problem with this
approach which is
the attributes of the elephant
or of any object for the sake is not in
the object
those attributes are made by the brain
so
that's where we are right now
we are at is what i can call a blind
alley and we are trying to find our way
out from this blind area
so what do you think is is the way out i
mean i'm not sure that everybody would
agree so i don't want to put words in
anybody's mouth but if one agrees that
this is a blind alley
what do you think is the way forward
what what is what are we missing is it
is it a radical change of perspective do
you just need to add something to the
mix in order to have a more complete
framework
well an alternative what i call the
brain-centric view
the one i'm promoting is that we learn
from our actions
the task of the brain if there is a task
you know evolutionary tasks is to serve
the body and the consequences
predict the consequences of our actions
now let me explain the difference
between the two frameworks in practical
neuroscience terms
so what we have been doing for decades
is that we present something to the
brain be it an experimental animal or a
human brain and we record from inside
the brain and it could be an electrical
pulse that we are picking up
in michael kahana's lab or it could be a
bald signal that that images get and
then we correlate the two and then we
say oh wow there's a nice correlation
between a moving pattern and the neurons
firing a particular way in the visual
cortex for example
we can go further on and the
eddy showed a very nice example that we
can train a
a computational algorithm we say
we make these systems smart it's so
smart that now it can we can reverse the
process we are recording from brain
activity and from the previous learning
we can reconstruct
what
would be
for example the music what would be the
language from the brain patterns
there is a catch here
the catch is that
the experimenter
is in a privileged situation
only the experimenter has access to the
world outside there
and the activity of the brain inside
here
neurons in the brain
have no clue
what's going on in the outside world
neurons will just get action potentials
from their partners and they have no
clue whether those action potentials
mean anything outside
in other words
this approach does have no grounding
as i mentioned you know grounding is a
process where the unknown is grounded to
the known
and there is only
one source of knowledge
that neurons can have besides what's
coming in from the outside world and
this is action
on output now action of course is a is a
typical way you think you are moving
your arms or you moving your eyes or do
something like that but action is also
the action on your heart the action on
your your your endocrine
system and thought is also an action
now the good news is
that every action system in the brain
informs
it sends out an output not only to the
body but it also informs the rest of the
brain
that i have sent out an output
now
neurons in the visual codecs for example
can deal with two types of information
what is that is coming from outside the
what is coming from here so this is the
way and the only way how i can say that
i am the actor
i am the agent of my own actions
so
this is a
fundamental difference between the two
approaches and i would say
let me give you an example no amount of
staring a stick in water
or no amount of argument between you and
me we would agree that the stick is
broken
or not but a little movement
a little action there immediately will
reveal to the brain that
the stick is not broken the source of
knowledge in the traditional outside in
model is the assumed richness of the
world
waiting to be observed by a camera-like
brain
in contrast in the inside out framework
knowledge comes from action blaze
exploration
and everything is compared and valued
from the organism's point of view no
exploration no knowledge
so so i so i gather and
i apologize if this is a course summary
but you want to kind of close the loop
where the brain
does receive stimuli from the external
world but it also acts on the external
world which then affects the stimuli we
receive from the external world and
that's this loop of of information that
is required for the brain to have
grounding for it to know that there's an
external world to know what these neural
firings are actually corresponding to in
the external sense
but
what is the definition of action and i
ask for the following reason so as you
noted action in the most straightforward
is just moving the arms and the legs and
salsa horse but you also mentioned
it can be the action of one neuron
sending an outward signal within the
brain itself so can action be a
completely inner process or does it need
to
access the external world
it doesn't have to need to to to have
any access to the external world i'll
give you an example
when you are born
before you are born
we all kick
you know baby kicks are very very
important
and the baby kicks correlate with the
apgar score and the
intelligence quotient 20 years later and
so so they are very important what they
do is
help the brain to build a body map
and it's a very fascinating
mechanism namely that every single time
there is this dumb teacher that some
muscle activity is is there it sends
back
a signal to the future sensory
somatosensory representation
now
of course this is a not a random process
because the skeletal system confines how
those muscles can move so now the
agonists and the antagonists are
represented together in time when i
happen to move my left arm or i happen
to move my my finger as a baby or as a
fetus and and those timing effects
because their proximity in time they
allow that neurons when they grow in
they will make the connections
appropriately so this is how we make a
map of the body and we
build it up and update it every day
because
every week the distance between your
finger and your nose is it varies so it
has to be updated so this is an example
of how
a
actual system can teach and make
sensation
meaningful
no amount of sensation you can have your
camera
uh your eyes everything and you can give
any amount of information through
sensors to a robot that robot just
remains dumb
without testing
the
the distance between me and the tree and
the between me and the mountain i have
no clue that the mountain is bigger or
smaller than a tree so only through this
action-based calibration can sensation
make sense so i just want to comment on
that because again it's observation from
the patients but despite the fact that i
describe this shift from an total
internal focus in these depressed
patients to the capacity
to interact outside themselves and to
get the feedback and what we see over
time is exactly what yuri is talking
about it takes time to recalibrate
one's own internal body
and its relationship to the outside
world and you're watching over months we
actually saw a patient for a 10-year
follow-up last week who when she tried
to describe in retrospect every stage of
recovery
she was realizing that updating her own
external internal map had been an
ongoing process
and that when she tried to identify
yeah she remembered in the operating
room but that was
minor compared to actually taking a year
or two to really trust her
representation of her internal state the
outside world and to feel that there was
dynamical predictions that she could
make and learn and so i'm i'm uh i'm a
fan of how yuri is conceptualizing it
even at if at the neuron to neuron level
we have no idea but the
the metaphors that patients use the
experience that they have is there is no
depression per se it's just the absence
of capacity to do those ongoing updates
that probably is how we should really
look at what we see
so let me jump off from that to one
final question as we're running out of
time here i want to go back to uh eddie
chang
and a question that i'll ask eddie but
one that i'd like you all to weigh in on
if you have a perspective on it eddie
you you noted that
you go into the operating room and you
look at the brain itself
and you know that it's more than a
computer right you're not looking at a
motherboard with chips it's something
beyond a computer
but but from your years of of staring at
the brain and manipulating the brain and
trying to decode the brain where do you
come down on on the question that of
course has been kicked around for for
hundreds if not thousands of years
is consciousness right we really haven't
spoken about consciousness here and some
of you may roll your eyes at the idea of
consciousness and if that's your
response i'd be happy to hear it but
when it comes to consciousness
is it within this physical structure is
that all that there is or do you find
that it's even inadequate for that
purpose that you think there has to be
something beyond the physical in order
for us to have the kinds of inner worlds
that happen inside of our heads
yeah brian thanks for um thanks for
asking that question and from a
physician's perspective we we think
about consciousness in fairly concrete
terms in terms of whether someone is
awake or not awake
there's some very very important medical
definitions that we use to define
and there are
specific parts of the brain
for example the brain stem and the
thalamus
the areas of michael halassis studies
very intensely and how they interact
with the cortex that need to be intact
in order to have conscious awareness
there's a lot of other aspects of
conscious awareness and subjective
perception and
our appreciation of the environment and
and that kind of awareness but in terms
of the basic fundamental
idea of being awake versus asleep
from my understanding the way i see it
is that it's an emerging property
that results from the interactions of
some very very core
structures in the brain including the
thalamus and other subcortical areas you
can see that when people have brain
injuries in some of these areas they may
never fully wake up
from those strokes or traumatic brain
injuries where in other parts of the
brain there's no effect whatsoever even
that you can detect
in many cases so the location the
substrate the hardware is very
fundamental
to this the operation implementation of
how
the neurons
in these particular brain locations give
rise to conscious awareness
is is a fascinating question that a lot
of people are working on now and it's
very much related to all of our work
michael halasa how about your views
consciousness purely physical something
else will will a computer ever be able
to have the kind of inner worlds that we
do i mean i think it's a great question
brian i think you mean by consciousness
you mean phenomenal consciousness the
the experience of i mean the thing
that's happening right between my ears
right now what it is to be me what is it
to have a perspective what is it to have
you know the redness of red the
qualitative experience of the outside
world i mean i think we're missing
something really fundamental in our
description of science altogether to be
able to arrive at a at an answer to the
question would a computer have
consciousness or not does an aunt have a
consciousness
does anybody else other than me uh have
consciousness i i think you know we we
just don't know i mean we don't really
have
the the the theoretical framework to be
able to answer a question of this of
this nature i mean i'd like to think
that you know other people other than me
are do have an internal experience and
do have do see green and red in in ways
that are similar to me
and by extension i can imagine dogs and
cat doing the same thing and if and i do
believe fundamentally that the brain is
generating processes that can be
approximated in in artificial uh
uh sort of in machines and therefore i
don't see a reason why machines won't be
able to experience things that are
similar to that but again i can't tell
you how yeah
helen any thoughts on the physical basis
of conscious awareness versus something
else um the short answer is no and i
think you know we these are surrogate
discussions and when we have a readout
um i'm not even sure that we would know
that we know that that's what we're
talking about but um i'll leave that to
philosophers and
neuroscientists that think they're
studying it
yuri
the the dream
that we dream together is reality
so that's a nice metaphor and we can go
this way but you ask concrete questions
whether my consciousness that is brian's
consciousness has something to do with
your brain and only with the brain my
answer is definitely no
and this is a connection between the
computer and the your brain and your
eyes are rolling now i can see your
brain is calibrated not by the physical
world only but also by my brain and
brains of many many many many others so
this reflection
of your actions back to you
or back to the brain is what gives rise
to something that you know we are we are
talking about
and and of course you know you can ask
also whether computers can have it
uh well right now what we do is all that
information that give give to the
computers usually there's one computers
don't or robots don't communicate with
each other so it is an unfair comparison
between
you know a few billion people's
knowledge compared to one of few
machines that thousands and thousands of
people to put together
the competition or the real thing would
be that we have
at least a million robots running around
in the world and they would
team up against us and then would they
collaborate and things like that that's
where we would talk about the funny part
you know
whether we could be outsmarted or not
right michael khan i'm giving you the
last word consciousness anything you
want to share
i think that the most interesting things
that the brain does are the things that
it's not consciously aware of it's all
that stuff behind the veil of
consciousness that is working in the
background
and that may underlie
for example why somebody might
ultimately become depressed right or or
why their their memories of events that
happened long ago are are doing stuff to
affect their future behavior they're not
even aware of it i think we want to
understand all of that stuff the inside
stuff that sometimes doesn't come out
immediately but may come out at an
inopportune moment
uh i i'd really like to understand those
processes well i i just
like to reiterate what michael kahana
said and several of you
that
what is me
me is my memories if you take away my
memories am i aware of my surroundings
god knows it's kind of a you know you
are a zombie you can react and it's hard
to tell whether you are the same brian
then uh five minutes ago but without
your past you you cannot have that kind
of consciousness that
philosophy is not talking about
yeah no i mean
the fact that collections of particles
can hold on to a lifetime of memories as
we were talking before giving us a
consistent identity through time is of
course the essence of what it means to
be human so from this human being to you
five human beings from these brain
patterns to yours i thank you so much
for this conversation on the brain it
was deeply fascinating and illuminating
thank you for joining us thank you thank
you
[Music]
you